はい先に進めてください
山本さん週末どうでした日本国籍で
ニューヨークでビジネスされたんですね
はい先に進めてください
そうですね家族みんなでお台場行ってき
ました佐藤さんは永住権を持ちの
アメリカ人でご両親とクリスマスを過ごす
ために埋める以下に行かれますはい先に
進めてくださいと彼女と一緒にスパイダー
マーニーにできましたスパイダーマンは
いいですね都市がボールで敢行
はい先に進めてくださいメキシコ留学から
帰国はい先に進めてください紅米市民の
アメリカ人で地元のロスで新聞記事の研究
はい先に進めてくださいインド人で東京
大学に留学しに留学しに切ったんですか
はい
はいえーと山本賛成今の話を上の方に伝え
てもらってもいいですか
少々待ってください越冬次の方どうぞすい
ません今学費を半年分払っている留学生が
入国審査の方に来ているんですけどあり等
で新婚良好はい先に進めてくださいやオン
ライン授業は受けてきたんですけどおじい
さのせいで毎日2時に起きなきゃいけない
らしくてドイツ人で日本でライブをしに
z 3私大ファンですそれがですね喜んで
隔離するって言ってるんですよ
いや実費で一番好きな曲ですかえっとすら
うざーど大衆のライブでぜひ流してくださ
承知しましたそうですね z 3の隔離は
もう3日間でいいですね本当にいいんです
かそれで念願のグローバル人材ですよよ今
z さんと話したよまあ承知しましたはい
失礼します
佐藤さん私と変わってもらってもいいです
かわかりましたお願い上海大変お待たせし
ました今自分の上司と話をしたんですけど
状況がとても不安定なのでバンコクで
ビジネスはい先に進めてください残念
ながら現時点で入国許可を出せませ
ロンドンで敢行
はい先にす
あそうなんですよ z 3ですよ
いきますそうですよね今後の方針ですよね
そう聞かれたらこう伝えて下さいと言われ
ました
検討てわかりますか
re savex
terrex to
do 新兵に少しでも鶴竜をさせた方が
良いと思いますいい物新品に必要なのは
パスバーガーソーラーうーん